so is it true that when Tom Cruz was
talking to you about doing Top Gun you
were originally interested in playing
rooster Miles Teller who's the son of
Anthony Edwards goose and it was sort of
the new Iceman Val Kilmer if you will
role that he wanted you to do you turned
it down and then he sought you out to
convince you otherwise is any of this
folklore that's all true
yeah it's all true he um okay first of
all that takes serious gonus to walk
away from a Top Gun Legacy franchise and
Tom Cruz yeah at the time it I was like
you know I had auditioned for that role
and when I didn't get it I was
definitely like this other role was just
not a great role and I didn't think I'd
do a good job and so Tom kept calling
and was like Hey I really want to talk
to you about this role and so when I sat
down and actually talked to him about it
he pitched me about how he works and he
basically said you're going to have to
trust me he goes I know what you do and
I know what you do really well and I'm
going to write this role with you you
were going to develop the role together
and I ended up taking the leap of faith
and trusting him and it turned out to be
the best decision I ever made I heard he
said something too which I really
responded to which is it isn't what is
written it's what you also bring to it
and make of it which is I think some of
the best acting advice Steven SPI said
don't act your characters be your
characters and I feel like that Tom Cruz
kind of goes in that box to keep of ways
to move forward in the tapestry of the
body of work you want to build
yes oh Red Light confession oh my God
confession okay favorite guilty pleasure
TV show I I will watch anything on HTV
me too cuz we love design Sweeny designs
is something something we're we're
working are you a Swifty yes me too
obsessed oh my God like kind of giving
her like Compass status in my life I'm
like she's just dating and living her
life and she's living her life she
doesn't care she's like I'm going to be
happy her soundtrack to life is
everything I can listen to all of her
albums over and over and reape them who
are you loving right now who inspires
too we we've appreciated Taylor Glen a
Swifty I I know every word never I grew
up with a house full of girls like
confession with yours yeah uh what's the
one thing from childhood you just can't
throw away um I still have the teddy
bear and blankie that I went home from
the hospital with wow I saved my
daughter's baby blankets from the
hospital no like mine's still in my
bedroom it's your bedroom yeah it's
Teddy and Blinky keep that forever oh by
the way I just want to present you with
something because I know this is already
coming so maybe it's like a practice run
um
I'm telling you this is going to happen
this is amazing so if you it's so heavy
thank you so much as um this is our this
is our real life meute we actually so
the first time we ever met Glenn was
presenting me and MTV movie o that's how
we met so so literally for best fight I
I handed Sydney the golden popcorn and
she looked at me like this and then she
decided to cast me to romcom so yeah
rest's history this is as they say so
Bashar and I don't know how many
categories and wins you're going to be
nominated for for this film but you put
something out into the world that we all
really need right now Glen I'm such an
Uber fan of your work and Miss Sweeny
you know how much I love you so much and
I'm so impressed with your produc
orial prowess in this film well done
thank you so much
like perfect Perfection I love you both
so much thank you for taking this
[Music]
time